so I just watched the documentary for
Unga on Netflix and if you haven't seen
it yet you should Moringa is a national
park in the eastern part of the
Democratic Republic of Congo that's
incredibly beautiful and imperiled by
poachers oil interests and war
counterparts around ready disparate
watching the Park Rangers defend varun
go with their lives literally made us
want to celebrate not just the heroes in
that film but elsewhere in Africa so
here's our list of environmental heroes
you should know about in the movie for
Unga we see park ranger Andre Bulma put
his life on the line for the endangered
mountain gorillas in his camp it's an
important task since there are only 880
mountain gorillas left in the world
she's somos la moon when rebel fighting
against DRC government threatens the
park
bomba refuses to leave his post and as
Virunga has gotten movie awards buzz
bomb a simple message is reaching a huge
audience Negril song is an emoji song
present Porto pool my a meaningful
truth-telling manatee on chair South
African activist Desmond Dessau won a
2014 Goldman environmental prize for his
work in South Durban South Durban is an
industrial hub that's home to oil
refineries chemical plants and 300,000
working-class residents the area has
been called cancer Valley for its high
cancer rates not to mention asthma so
when a controversial landfill of toxic
waste was up for lease renewal to saw
rallied the community
he helped residents measure air quality
without fancy technology connected them
to legal aid collected landfill samples
at night and made a general stink in the
media the result the landfill closed and
even though his house was firebombed in
what seems like an attempt to silence
him de saw is still pushing for change
Raoul de Toilette vilde life
conservation throughout Zimbabwe a
Zimbabwean himself de Toit's dedicated
his life to protecting endangered black
rhinos black rhinos have been poached
for decades for their horns and the
world's population has declined by
almost 97% since 1960
so Dutoit founded the lovel dry no trust
in 2009 to give rhinos a safe home with
poaching on the rise over the past few
years due Toit's work is more necessary
than ever our last hero isn't just one
person we're talking about 15,000 600
fishermen in Nigeria who demanded that
shell clean up the huge mess it made two
massive shell oil spills in 2008 and
2009 devastated the boto community in
the Niger Delta but the fishermen fought
back in a lawsuit that just came to an
eighty four million dollar settlement
the spills which shell admits were
caused by a faulty pipeline killed fish
polluted water and even caused headache
and eyesight problems shell will give
each fisherman 3,300 dollars and the
fishermen's lawyer says the company has
promised to clean up bodo Creek they've
better so those were just a few of the
inspiring environmentalists we've heard
about did we miss anyone let us know